VICTIMS' FAMILIES AND THE PUBLIC
ON SUNDAY.
LET'S BRING IN ROSA FLORES.
WALK US THROUGH WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO SEE HERE.
>> YOU KNOW, JAKE, BEFORE WE
SHOW YOU THIS VIDEO, WE NEED TO
SHARE WITH OUR VIEWERS THAT THIS
IS AN EDITED VIDEO PRODUCED BY
THE AUSTIN AMERICAN STATESMAN.
IT IS ABOUT FOUR MINUTES LONG.
IT DOES NOT INCLUDE THE FULL 77
MINUTES OF THE ACCOUNT OF WHAT
HAPPENED.
NOW, THE AUSTIN AMERICAN
STATESMAN DECIDED TO EDIT OUT
THE CHILDREN, THE VOICES OF THE
CHILDREN THAT WERE IN THIS
VIDEO, AND THEN CNN HAS DECIDED
TO EDIT OUT THE AUDIO OF THE
GUNFIRE.
WE SHOULD BE VERY CLEAR HERE,
THIS IS A VERY GRAPHIC VIDEO.
IT COULD TRIGGER PEOPLE WATCHING
THIS IN OUR AUDIENCE.
YOU HAVE TO BE VERY CAREFUL IF
YOU DECIDE TO WATCH THIS VIDEO.
NOW, WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO SEE IS
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE THE GUNMAN
ENTER THE SCHOOL WITH THAT
RIFLE.
HE'S GOING TO ENTER, HE'S GOING
TO MAKE A RIGHT, GO DOWN THE
HALL.
THERE'S A CHILD THERE OBSERVING
ALL OF THIS.
THEN THE GUNMAN STARTS AND OPENS
FIRE.
THEN YOU'RE GOING TO SEE THAT
HALLWAY EVENTUALLY FILL WITH
POLICE OFFICERS.
BUT THE VIDEO STARTS OFF AT THE
BEGINNING WHEN THE GUNMAN
CRASHES NEAR THE SCHOOL.
>> THE KIDS ARE RUNNING.
>> GET IN THE ROOM.
GET IN YOUR ROOM
!
>> IT'S DIFFICULT TO FIND WORDS
FOLLOWING THAT FOUR MINUTES.
WE ARE STARTING TO GET WORD FROM
FAMILIES, THE FAMILIES OF THE
VICTIMS WHO HAVE SEEN THIS
VIDEO.
THEY ARE VERY UPSET.
SOME OF THEM TAKING TO FACEBOOK,
SAYING THAT THIS IS THE OPPOSITE
OF WHAT THE FAMILY WANTED.
I'M GOING TO QUOTE HERE, OUR
HEARTS ARE SHATTERED ALL OVER
AGAIN.
AND JAKE, THIS IS -- THIS VIDEO
IS COMING JUST DAYS BEFORE THE
TEXAS HOUSE INVESTIGATIVE
COMMITTEE WAS PLANNING TO HAVE A
PRIVATE MEETING WITH THE
FAMILIES OF THE VICTIMS TO SHARE
WITH THEM THE FULL 77 MINUTES OF
THE HALLWAY VIDEO.
AND ALSO A FACT FINDING REPORT,
AND ALSO ANSWER THEIR QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE INVESTIGATION.
SO THAT'S WHAT THE FAMILIES WERE
PREPARING THEMSELVES FOR, TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION IN
PRIVATE, TO BE ABLE TO EXPRESS
THEIR FRUSTRATIONS, TO ASK
QUESTIONS.
AND HERE WE ARE AGAIN, SHARING
THIS STORY OF ANOTHER YET
PIECEMEAL ACCOUNT OF WHAT
HAPPENED THAT DAY.
>> AND ROSA, AS YOU AND I HAVE
DISCUSSED FOR THE LAST SEVEN
WEEKS, WE NEED TO REMIND OUR
VIEWERS THAT THE VERY FIRST
THING THE POLICE AND THE
POLITICIANS DID AFTER THIS
HORRIFYING MASSACRE WAS PRAISE
THEMSELVES AND HOW BRAVE THEY
WERE AND HOW COURAGEOUS THE
RESPONSE WAS.
THAT WAS THE FIRST THING, AND
IT'S ONLY BECAUSE THE FAMILIES
AND JOURNALISTS WERE ASKING
QUESTIONS THAT WE NOW HAVE AN
ACCURATE PICTURE OF WHAT
HAPPENED.
DOES THE COMMITTEE PLAN TO
RELEASE THIS VIDEO, THE FULL 77
MINUTES, EARLIER NOW THAT THE
AUSTIN AMERICAN STATESMAN HAS
PUBLISHED THIS EDITED VERSION
ONLINE?
>> YOU KNOW, I TALKED TO A
SOURCE CLOSE TO THE COMMITTEE,
AND THIS SOURCE TELLS ME THAT
THEY PLAN TO DO WHAT THEY WERE
PLANNING TO DO, WHICH IS RELEASE
THIS VIDEO TO THE FAMILIES FIRST
ON SUNDAY IN UVALDE, SO IN THEIR
OWN TOWN.
AND TO ANSWER THEIR QUESTIONS,
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY CONTINUE TO
DO.
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE,
REPRESENTATIVE BOROUGHS TWEETING
MOMENTS AGO, EXPRESSING HIS
DISAPPOINTMENT OF THIS LEAK
BECAUSE THEY WERE REALLY HOPING
TO TAKE THE FAMILIES THROUGH T